en este vídeo quiero hablar acerca del
concepto de apalancamiento nada más va a
ser una introducción en vídeos futuros
pues vamos a hablar un poquito más
acerca de qué se trata porque es bueno
porque es malo vamos a hablar de son
muchos contextos pero ahorita nos vamos
a enfocar en los bancos entonces
empecemos una vez más con el banco
empezamos con 300 piezas de oro en
capital 300 piezas de oro y pues otra
vez ya sabes hacemos un edificio
construimos una bóveda para ponerle aquí
que es la bóveda bóveda usamos 100
piezas de oro lo restante que son 200
piezas lo ponemos en la bóveda los
ponemos ahí para empezar el negocio 200
piezas de oro y luego recibimos
depósitos vamos a poner un depósito de
100 piezas de oro que en contraparte
tiene un pasivo tiene un pasivo también
de 100 piezas de oro y vamos a pensar
que es una cuenta de cheques ya sabes la
gente lo usa para escribirse cheques oa
lo mejor puede venir y reclamar su oro
no importa bueno ya con esto vamos a
empezar a hacer algunos préstamos para
algunos proyectos
vamos a poner aquí el proyecto de a que
son 300 piezas de oro es un préstamo de
300 y para hacer eso simplemente abrir
una cuenta de cheques para ar
entonces son 300 piezas de oro en una
cuenta de cheques muy bien déjame hacer
otro préstamo puede hacer otro préstamo
por acá otra vez pues otra vez de 300
piezas de oro ahora es un préstamo para
ve y otra vez pues voy a abrir una
cuenta de cheques puede haber emitido
billetes pero vamos a pensar que es una
cuenta de cheques va ya platicamos de
requisitos de reserva pero ahora vamos a
hablar de apalancamiento apalancamiento
esencialmente es cuántos activos
controlas con cierta cantidad de capital
favorita cuánto es nuestro capital el
capital es de 300 verdad el capital es
igual a 300 piezas de oro bueno eso de
ahí sería el capital
voy a pintarlo con otro color para que
resalte y que no se confunda con el
pasivo
pues cuántos activos tenemos con esos
trescientos de capital pues a ver aquí
va 400 700 y 300 son 1000 entonces los
activos los activos es de 1000 muy ahora
muchas veces cuando la gente habla
acerca de apalancamiento pues dice
cierta razón entonces vamos a hablar de
la razón entre el capital y los activos
ahorita cuando tenemos haber activos al
capital que es lo que usualmente se
conoce como apalancamiento
apalancamiento cuánto es sería mil a 300
simplificando en un poquito nos quedaría
un diez a tres verdad diez a tres
apalancamiento de diez a tres usualmente
ves como tres a uno o cuatro a uno o dos
a uno cosas a uno pero diez a tres
también es una razón éste validaba
entonces esto nos dice cuántos activos
verdad estos de aquí controlamos con
cierta cantidad de capital y hay muchas
razones por las cuales los bancos se
fijan en este coeficiente no sé por
ejemplo si estamos ganando más dinero
de lo que estamos pagando en los pasivos
por intereses o lo que sea entonces al
banco le conviene tener tanto
apalancamiento como pueda porque es
justo justo cuando agregamos algunos
activos y pasivos pues si hay una
diferencia se hace una ganancia a partir
de ahí entonces pues los bancos les
gusta seguir haciendo eso y lo que sea
pero hay un lado malo qué pasaría si
algunos de estos préstamos no son tan
buenos si deja de borrar un poquito lo
que acabo de dibujar qué pasaría si
algunos de estos préstamos resultan ser
malos o sea son proyectos que fracasan
pues cuando el apalancamiento es alto y
las cosas van bien multiplica las
ganancias pero de modo similar si
tenemos un apalancamiento alto este
también se multiplican las pérdidas y
los proyectos son malos en esta
situación no sé supongamos que las cosas
no salen mal y hacemos cuentas y nos
damos cuenta que vamos a perder un 30 no
con un 50% de nuestros activos antes de
eso en un mundo sin apalancamiento
déjame hacer un ejemplo por acá voy a
hacerlo para que hagamos la comparación
entonces en un mundo sin apalancamiento
con 300 de capital
y 300 de activos si mis activos bajan en
50% observa que aquí no hay pasivo
verdad es puro capital a la derecha puro
capital a la izquierda son activos
entonces en este ejemplo si mis activos
por alguna razón éste no se bajan en 50%
mi nueva hoja de balance se vería así
déjame bajar un poquito se vería así
entonces 150 inactivos y acá 150 en
capital mi capital también bajó en 50
por ciento
perdí 50 por ciento porque hice malas
inversiones no fue tan grave pero ahora
qué pasa con el apalancamiento qué pasa
si mis activos bajan en valor
qué pasa si mis activos bajan no sé 50%
porque los préstamos veía pues ya sé que
no van a pagar muy bien o sea que ya
sobre fueron préstamos mal hechos vamos
a ver qué sucede entonces si baja en 500
la cantidad de mis activos no sé
supongamos que la deuda debe ahora nada
más vale 50 porque nada más puede pagar
eso y lo mismo pasa con la deuda de a
nada más puede pagar 50 y estas pérdidas
puede ser por cosas que no sean de mala
fe se realmente puede que el canal no
haya
y el puente se haya caído en fin que no
funcionará el proyecto la cosa es que no
fueron buenos préstamos y entonces ya
nada más me van a poder pagar 50 de las
300 piezas vamos a ver qué pasa en este
caso con la nueva hoja de balance
vamos aquí abajo a ver qué sucede ahora
tengo apalancamiento y se ve así otra
vez voy a poner los 100 de mi edificio
de ahí no perdí nada verdad
luego tengo aquí tengo 300 en depósitos
ese es el oro que tengo físico es esta
partecita de acá y luego qué sucede con
las deudas pues la primera deuda se
disminuye a sólo 50 y la segunda deuda
del segundo préstamo que hice baja a 50
cuánto tengo en total de activos 50 50
veces 100 y 300 400 y otros 100 dan 500
entonces en total tengo 500 en activos
lo cual es muy razonable porque dije que
había perdido el 50 por ciento de de mis
activos verdad antes tenía 1000
pues ahora como se ven los pasivos pues
debo estoy acá en cuenta de cheques esto
acá también en cuenta de cheques no sé
si son las mismas personas se lo debo a
alguien verdad son cosas que debo pero a
ver cuánto tengo tengo 300 en pasivo 300
me tengo que ir hasta acá abajo y
observa 700 observa ahora mi capital es
negativo vamos a hacer las cuentas para
que veas que el capital queda negativo
porque porque siempre los activos es
igual al pasivo más el capital
tenemos que activos es 500 pasivo de 700
entonces el capital debe de ser debe ser
negativo debe ser menos 200 el capital
es negativo y esencialmente lo que esto
quiere decir es que estoy en quiebra
este banco tiene que cerrar en esta
situación las cosas se ponen bien feas
porque justo como el banco está
endeudado pierde su confianza toda la
gente quiere sacar todo el dinero que
había depositado entonces los pasivos
así exigibles al instante vencen luego
luego y quizás lo más grave de todo es
que aunque le diéramos todo el tiempo al
banco como sus deudas ya no son buenas
como su pérdida en activos fue tan
catastrófica entonces ya no pueden
y pasivos a esta terrible situación se
le conoce como insolvencia deja la pongo
en azulito se le conoce como insolvencia
va esto simplemente quiere decir que no
tienes el dinero que prometiste y ojo
antes hablábamos de requisitos de
reserva pero estos tenían que ver con
liquidez o sea que si poníamos tantito
dinero aparte entonces usualmente
podríamos pagar el oro que nos pedían
pero a veces no ahí no era tan grave
porque tus deudas todavía eran buenas
entonces si contaban como activo y
entonces le podías decir a la gente pues
a cuéntame tantito si tengo pero
necesito esperar si puedes pagar pero no
inmediatamente insolvencias cuando ya no
puedes pagar sistema las inversiones y
por más que esperes como ya tienes menos
activos que pasivos ya de plano no vas a
pagar nunca en la vida por esta razón el
apalancamiento puede ser un riesgo mira
en el otro ejemplo sin apalancamiento
cuando tenías pérdidas podías
enfrentarlas sin mucho problema pero
ahora con sólo 10 a 3 de apalancamiento
una pérdida de 50 por ciento nos saca
del negocio y no sé por ejemplo un
apalancamiento de 10 a 1 haría que una
pérdida del 10% nos hiciera quebrar
ok entonces esto del apalancamiento nos
dice que colchoncito tenemos para
aguantar pérdidas en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a ver las regulaciones del
apalancamiento pero ahorita quiero darte
una definición de alternatiba acá arriba
estamos calculando activos contra
capital otra forma de calcular el
apalancamiento que se usa frecuentemente
en el mundo de las inversiones es
calcular la razón entre la deuda y el
capital deuda contra capital y realmente
es una medida de lo mismo si conoces
deuda contra capital puedes conocer
activo contra capital vamos a ver cuánto
nos da en el ejemplo el total de deuda
es 300 más 300 más tiene 700 el total de
deuda 700 el capital 300 700 a 300 es 7
a 37 a 3 es la razón deuda contra
capital esa es otra medida de
apalancamiento nos vemos